for more information on tutoring or how
to support moofy university and the
production of more videos please visit
moof university com thank you and enjoy
so in the last video we discussed the
wave nature of electrons which are
classically viewed as particles and in
this video we're going to explore the
particle nature of light or of photons
we actually have already mentioned this
we've already mentioned that light which
is classic we viewed as a wave behavior
as if it's made up of tiny particles
that are called photons so in this video
what we're going to do is we're going to
realize that using de broglie's equation
we can calculate the momentum which is
represented by P for a photon with a
certain wavelength okay so momentum is
actually equal to mass times velocity
and it's a property that is conserved in
the same way that energy is conserved
but in this case we're not going to take
it to be equal to M equals or m equal to
M times V we're going to take V to be
just the speed of the particle that
we've mentioned was view okay so this
here is the de Broglie wavelength
equation and you'll notice at the bottom
here we have M times you so that's
basically what momentum is so we can
replace M times you with P so we'll have
the wavelength is equal to Planck's
constant over P and from there we can
just solve for momentum and get that
momentum is equal to Planck's constant
divided by lambda okay so what does this
mean this means that the momentum is
inversely proportional to the wavelength
so if we have a smaller wavelength we
have a larger momentum if you divided by
a smaller wavelength the momentum is
value gets bigger the opposite is true
if you have a larger wavelength if you
have a smaller momentum okay now I put a
new and energy here but that's sort of
really just there for recall if you have
a lower wavelength you have a
higher frequency and a higher energy
right this is from the sequel and a new
equation and this is from the e equals H
new equation of course you have a higher
wavelength to have a lower frequency and
a lower energy as well ok so in 1923
arthur compton shine some x-ray photons
at graphite and notice something
interesting so he had x-ray photons
coming in x-ray photons coming in with a
certain wavelength and they reflected
with a different wavelength specifically
the the wavelength that reflected off of
the graphite was bigger than the one
that was in coming ok so he noticed like
I said that the reflected photons had a
larger wavelength and this means
something for momentum something is a
larger wavelength it has a smaller
momentum lower momentum so the momentum
of the reflected photons was less than
the momentum of the photons coming in so
momentum decreased now that's an issue
because momentum is conserved just like
energy is conserved that's a physics
concepts that don't don't get crazy if
you don't already know that what
momentum is conserved and if you're
coming in with a certain momentum and it
these these photons are coming in with a
certain momentum and they're leaving
with a smaller momentum where did the
rest of the momentum go right because
there's still some that has to be
accounted for what happened was that
photons transferred they transferred
their momentum at least some of it to
the electrons in the graphite which is a
particle-like behavior light is coming
in and with a certain
and leaving with less momentum because
some of the momentum was transferred to
the electrons that were actually in the
graphite so that that happening the
transferring of that momentum is a
portal particle like property so this is
just a further sort of evidence behind
the idea that light has a particle
nature so I hope that video was helpful
thank you for watching if you found that
video helpful don't forget to Like
comment subscribe and share with friends
thank you and happy studying